I can always go daddy I need money what
and so when I was in when I was when I
was in theater school and acted in New
York my daddy went over acting
did but how come you so bad what do you
think it all because I think you know
the history the economics thing I guess
Andrew I do I have ten dollars and
someone takes two how many do I have
left eight okay Grady great econ and
great history we learned both of these
things out of you but the acting thing
is so bad no dude you are so so bad that
I don't think I've ever seen one thing
that line you know what give me a
scenario you're mine I'll give it I made
him an offer he can't refuse all right
go ahead I made him an offer I can't
refuse
be - [ __ ] you E - dude do you want to
see how to really do it yeah please okay
how'd you get him now I have to I'll
give you the line to feed in how did you
get him to agree now hold up let start
it and get let see this one talking
about amateur an actor prepares did you
give us action Kohut action how'd you
get him to agree I made him an offer he
couldn't refuse and scene dude that's
okay here's the new see the difference
do you see the difference yeah I am
moded more I turned I did it-- there was
body movements and then you were saying
when you were in acting class though if
it if it didn't work out you were just
like [ __ ] it go back to Papa
I had a no I mean no my ego was too big
that what saved me was the fact that I
just like being good at things I didn't
want to be the dork I want to be the
cool kid
we know I was the cool personality I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna be not I'm not
gonna not be successful at something if
I'm gonna go for it okay why my boxing
my dancing my [ __ ] my acting
everything so whatever but here's the
thing you're good at two of those things
don't dancing yeah don't say boxing no
not mocking alright what was the other
one Oh [ __ ] you can dance and [ __ ]
from what I hear no I know it alright I
pounded this guy Oh God
i dude for your fans by the way I'll
take back all the money jokes that I'm a
because that's that's disgusting that's
not who I am okay I want them to know
that that's not who I am this is a joke
but what's not a joke is I [ __ ] Bryan
Callen I have had sex with Bryan Callen
I want the world to know man top top no
no top on the bottom and the top on the
bottom and the guy who films it yes you
do yeah goes our whole [ __ ] secret
with the mustache over there he's like
really a dude right there right there
that that's a poster for gay men who
does like that think I've shown as Bush
we saw earlier if you're in a gay
farmers if you're if you're in a
redheaded gay farmers that guy with the
mustache pick an apple and [ __ ] you're
right right man if you like to pick
apples and get banged by our my carrot
you want me to dump in your mouth hey
keep going down with little Dickie good
dude I mean look at me as a kid on the
lake and Lake Michigan there get out of
my face with an attitude just kid I got
my lookit I got my Lacoste shirt on you
look 40 super [ __ ] baby there's another
one there's gotta be boy there's more
for serious keep going got me naked show
Bryan than one Amin ABC let me take in
the [ __ ] by the way I'm not mad at the
body well done sir what are you doing
well I had to jerk off on Showtime we
did a nude scene right sure I'm jerking
off and I get a phone call that my dad
is dead let's go down look at that
basketball camp Duke and UNC there you
go getting cuter on the left then we got
Bronco City you've got struggle city is
good hold on keep going you're doing
that Aurora's like a [ __ ] good
teacher I rented a Ferrari for the
Showtime promo we did I rented the 90 I
went to that 95 I wanted the one that
Jordan was in love it keep going down
keep that's me wait oh that's me 45 go
up in the red look at the red shirt I
said I'm Jerry Mix Seinfeld look at me
big jeans bro well big jeans are oh
what's the deal with big jeans
those are like I can hear my guesses I
can hear my dad go tuck it in tuck it in
but I don't like talking in
[ __ ] off for face kids you just make up
mean things to say need it but or not I
couldn't I heard so many [ __ ]
annoying
fire-crotch Opie's and a fire crotch
Opie
I had a pepperoni head because I also
had pimples it was worse it was like a
pimpled redheaded kid I mean that's why
I says I you know what about big red big
red it's kind of endearing I call myself
red big red the chewing gum though you
know do you know one call you hot sauce
hot sauce is cool too I don't mind any
that stuff odd being made me hot sauce
hot sauce hot sauce hot sauce the
retards coming in you know Here Come hot
sauce no it was always older kids that
thought it was funny to make fun of me
in front of chicks no he's always I was
actually in front of dudes
that's because chicks still have
sympathy their whole lives men don't get
sympathy but like girls even they're
young and they see someone being mean to
say I don't like it they're like oh
that's mean it's not a way to win over
no chicks don't like dudes or [ __ ]
to make other dudes laugh correct the
dude that said yeah exactly it's like
the wacom say we but like if I walk in
with [ __ ] leopard pants on I'm gonna
get gonna get lickin the [ __ ] let's do a
we bond but that's because we're friends
but when people are being like racist
like when someone said that to chin when
somebody said pan face he's trying to
make somebody else laugh by being mean
to him correct and not God we never cuz
of a girl no never never a girl with Joe
would never go oh that guy that picks on
everybody is so cute ooh did you hear
Jeremy called the Asian Panthers I'm
gonna suck I love that God never
happened not ever bully but that was it
was a fire crotch or or or or Opie oh it
was actually Opie
you know Opie Taylor yeah Ron Howard
that was actually he was killing it that
was at me at elementary school that was
always the older black kids would say
that to me but it was it was a term of
endearment so like it didn't hurt my
feelings but it didn't know me yeah you
come hey what's up I'll be here come out
because if older black dudes would
always do that that's very cool I will
stop Opie
yeah but they're mocking me yeah but
also your Opie
but it's cool that the black guys notice
right yeah in Dermott father in the red
rocket
[ __ ] Callen it's over Bry you old ass
piece of [ __ ] oh man it's so gonna be
here thank you for letting me put up my
art do I like how long does it take you
to make six seconds that's how good is
good though scribble it out it looks
good you you your turn eighteen Rookie
of the Year and I'm glad you're here
campaign because we got this little man
look at how tight this is oh my god you
earned it man what you earned it I feel
like I said I want to make a little
speech at least do dude this is uh this
is for this for all the haters out there
this for everyone that said I couldn't
do it [ __ ] you're wrong I proved you
wrong again and again and again and I'm
gonna keep on proving you wrong and I'm
taking over this podcast that's an
announcement I wanted to make to you
guys good it's no longer the fighter and
the kid okay the kid is dead the kid is
gone it is fight on the red rock
forevers algebra thank you so much you
guys thank you so much you earned it
machine hand made this huh oh god this
is so nice can told me that tape that
after hours that these guys may make you
make Samsung phones is that you have to
make a day 35 what tomorrow no are you
are you what are you Italian Irish half
half Italian and Irish Siciliano me too
you see the difference is I look I look
Irish yeah and I've got the body in the
[ __ ] of an Italian okay I don't know you
look like like a little tiny Swedish boy
you are like a little Swedish boy
yourself it may be little tiny Swedish
boy I got time I'm a Brian a Calum yeah
you know they're tangible I can either
Brian a Calum that's an Irish guy and I
know horrible swims this is an Irish guy
this is clearly Irish man whoa do yes
that's Irish in Jamaican no this is a
Irish guy that's so Jamaican this is I
okay welcome to Ireland no that's no
welcome to the island of Ireland man the
very land come over get some fish and
chips and fruit and salad no see that's
falafel this is Ireland
salad couscous on the island of Ireland
no that sounds soldier make it is not
even close did you make it Jamaican
accent you want to join ia I'm Jamaican
I'm a big black Jamaican guy everyone
knows I'm Jamaican that's Jamaican super
Australian you're so bad with dialects
you don't know I don't I studied in
college dude I did dialectical research
that was one of my focuses what was your
what was your major in college
journalism and English journalist in
journalism major English focus and I had
a dialectic subset I did two and a half
years of learning dialects around the
world came but name a place and I can do
it
Maori Maori you want Maori yeah okay
welcome to diesel nobody I uh I uh
pulled oh no mommy me hold you on
daughter sheep and you didn't understand
the language because I was also no he's
okay okay Russian Russian Russians
probably probably one of my favorites to
be honest with you Russians easy Russian
goes don't you want to eat you want to
eat fish with us or do you want to go on
your separate ways because dinner is
made okay now I have to all right that's
now looks I don't take this wrong way
but that does sound a little bit French
well you you're going you want me to go
do some more be alright can I hear these
and don't make it okay don't make it can
I hear it Joplin is easy Japanese is
probably one of my favorite ones to do
alright I have to get prepped for it
ready yeah
did you mine right who I dunno you know
how to do this with me I wanna dance on
your lap and maybe shake em up ooh
supposed to because it's so good did you
just get transform like you were back in
Tokyo Japan I'm so [ __ ] Spanish dude
it's very honestly papa
you guys are so wrong I maybe I am
you're wrong I went to a [ __ ] school
for dialectical research okay maybe
we're off I don't know maybe my go to
college I did go did you go to college
or did with college I went to American
University in DC DC yeah
that's a really good school I know it is
what did you do what was your major
history economics history then it was
history yeah economics and history well
it was economics and I switched over to
hist when was the war of 1812 that's a
good question you know this place I go I
went here once if I pass that once you
register in childhood I don't know I
feel like that most people a lot of time
remember certain things my childhood oh
I got a bunch of people in my life that
remember when they were five right no
what are they doing now it's a good
question one of them is my driver that's
actually pretty smart
yeah it's a good question he's outside
right now and I make him wait make him
sit and wait I say you think about your
childhood while I'm inside because it's
so I don't you should see what I do know
you had a drive you have a lot of money
reiver
plural I've drivers I don't have one
drive you mean to all of them no there's
one girl that I like but the two guys
piss me off everyday they didn't do it
like they didn't do anything I don't you
know what they're up to what this coffee
order was wrong my driver coffee wrong
threw it in his face as I go get me
another one burn his face it's iced
coffee I threw the iced coffees and in
and it knocked out one of his contacts
Ice Cube knocked out of his contact he's
crying in them in the parking lot of
Starbuck you know yeah I'll go get it
okay go get it I pass there's an intern
belt so you you're the defendant
champion Chris the in terms you know
what this sounds like to me was in try
over there sounds like I won good to win
your first of all I want to thank all my
fans my friends thank you so much for
coming out dude
these guys these guys tied I won so this
is your is this your way this is my win
speech let me make a speech real fast
I'm so happy to be guest of the year
I knew it everybody knew it I don't feel
neuen hook Andres Delano knew it
it's really what happened now that I'm
sitting on top of the mountain it feels
so good it feels so good to be in labor
now what are you talk oh my god I can't
thank you guys so much I want to thank
my
I'm gonna thank God wait till the speak
and I have my award speech please so
Louis see qu time the helm bro time bro
you own time you look like a very
weathered louis c.k [ __ ] huh you want
to see my dick i'll Louie CK you write
funny ass first
yes I would like he's got please please
he's like he's got a real dick on a man
with you really know it looks like I'm
not heard that's like a Red Bull not my
mom my mom's house oh cool man well she
lives in Aurora so I'm already been I'm
already there right now Oh mentally I'm
there okay physically I'm here I've been
walking around in this body but I left
my mind with your mom a long time ago I
gotta tell you bro he is a genius she's
smart she's sweet she's sexy okay she
can cook well I gotta tell you she can
cook maybe you never cook for you right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]